the left-hander heart major league
debuts
john d diaz the t-h and a ground ball
through the right side
rosso
will head to the plate the throw
will not be in time and the rays break
out in front
on a base headed to right field by yandi
diaz well it did not take long we talked
about it in the open the rays have been
clutch runners in scoring position and
as soon as that opportunity presents
itself yandi diaz cashes it in like the
raise far from done
and struck him out so he gets his first
out by fanning hunter renfro there you
go that's got to feel a little better
little backdoor cutter
gets a swing and a miss balls up upper
cut
first punch out nicely done to keep it
going
two on two out now
thomas sends it into right field pilar
will play it on one hop
and the throw to the plate will not be
in time martinez scores from second and
adamus does indeed keep it going to make
it two to nothing
boy i thought that ball off the bat may
hang up enough for pilar to get there
but he didn't look like he got a very
good jump at all and was not moving well
and that ball drops in front nice job by
martinez running on contact and tyler
glass now looking to get back on track
here and start number four and what you
want to see out of him is just a smooth
delivery
rafael he's going to knock that one the
other way for a base hit that'll drive
in verdugo and the red sox are on the
board here against last night an rbi for
debra is his fourth yeah ball stairs he
just fought this ball off that's all he
did
once again ball not hit that hard high
fast ball he just fights it off rbi
single for devers now plucky who has
been as hot as a firecracker seven for
14. he's done that before
slicer that one headed for the alley
that is down on the grass and up against
the wall
deborah's in the score martinez pounding
around here's the throw to the plate and
he will slide in
staying hot and puts the red sox in
front three to two as soon as he hit it
i said that is gabbage and two runs are
gonna score
at first pace here's hunter retro he
struck out his first time
when he sends this one deep into right
field that one is going to get out of
here dropping into the bullpen
an 02 count
and renfro hits his third home run of
the year it comes with diaz aboard and
the reigns will take a 4-3 lead
rbi's 12 and 13 for renfro
and he goes fastball and there this one
goes a shot deep and gone
up over the bullpens and into the seats
so brandon lau who for a moment
had seen renfro tie him for the team
lead and runs batted in
hits his fifth home run of the year and
retakes
the team rbi lead run number five and he
now has 14 runs batted in first and
third for tampa bay
it's a liner into right for a base hit
adamus will score the rays
put up another run an rbi single to
right for satsugo the rays now make it
three ron reneke's gonna head to the
mound
brings up our ooze his banning average
has skyrocketed
another breaking ball that one torn into
and a leaping effort over the head of
renfro
one run in to score
on a double by the red hot aura
oohs i'm telling you what this guy is on
fire
ball up the middle here comes diaz in to
score
and the rays pick up another run they
have again scored eight
tapper third base side bare hand pickup
and the throw is wide
fro
scores and lau goes to third margaux up
to second
and margot will get a base hit there'll
be a throwing error involved as well
the rays make it nine to four
jd rips a bullet toward the gap and left
center field is to get a run home it
hits off the web sign off the wall jd on
his way to second and the throw is wide
fortunately because a good throw might
have had him but a run scores and it is
ten to five
tampa bay
he has found a stroke in this series
and a renfro leading off
and the 2-0 and there's one
way down that left side and that ball is
gone
home run number
four the second of the night for hunter
rinfrow and he launched that one
this one the other way that's got some
carry going to be over the head of
pallar has a little trouble making the
pickup
lau is going to be waved around third
the throw to the plate is not in time
the raise add another run it's now
12-5
and now mike zadino
and a high-fly ball this one he got hold
of that and that baby is out of here
mike cenino unloads a three-run shot
that will give him four runs batted in
for the night and the rays
have a six-run inning
but not after coming off some of these
other games
ricochet that got
right to the bag at first to get the out
oh that's not good
as the run comes in to score
he took a hot shot 17-5 tampa bay
and perazo is only in there to try and
finish it up gets a
wicked liner back at him i mean i mean
that's scary now
now what you can't let him i mean he's
done rays have scored 42 runs in the
series
and that will end it a strike call
and the rays have swept
the boston red sox winning tonight
to 17-8 for the raise 17-19-0